uh tonight we have some very exciting
chess for you it is the corporate chess
league finals of the 2022 spring season
uh many have competed four teams have
made it to these the finals this year
and i'm super excited to see them face
off i think it's going to be a very
competitive night of chess i think all
of these teams have a fair shot at the
finals and i'm excited to see who can
who can get it done uh as you see on
your screen we have four finalist teams
we have enterprise edward jones
ascension and doherty and those are in
seeding order in the regular season
grand prix enterprise walked away with
the most points and they get the top
seed edward jones second best ascension
in a very very close race uh for second
place ends up in third but very much in
there with the shout and doughty gets
that last qualification spot uh now we
take you up to our tournament hall where
yes our players are back here in person
i'm super excited to have everybody here
in the building with me today normally
it's just me all alone and they're all
playing from home online but we've got
everybody in person you see the
wonderful mike cummer director of the
corporate chess league tonight uh
getting everybody going explaining the
rules making sure everybody understands
and uh over there let's see uh i'm not
sure which two teams that is actually
you know reading these people's
usernames not so easy to uh connect them
to their faces all the time but they're
ready to go they're squaring off over
there we've got two boards up on one
side of the tournament hall and i think
the other two boards are over there to
the left
uh
and
oh last second discussions they're
getting ready they're getting ready and
yeah you see uh i think that's a
budweiser there on board three of course
drinks are served at the corporate chess
league so look for the chess to get even
better as the night goes on um
but it's all in good fun these guys are
here to have fun they're here to play
some chess i'm excited to talk about
their games and you see we're on the
nice dgt sets today so i can follow
along the action live as it happens it's
gonna be super exciting
and there is our corporate chess league
commissioner alex curford all business
shakes hands clock gets started and alex
has made his first move we're well
underway so we've got some pretty
exciting matches in uh the first round
here it's going to be enterprise up
against doherty and i'm going to be
following along with their board one to
start with so we have alex schimel
fenning who to be honest with you is a
little bit of a wild card to me i don't
know who this is i don't know what
username he went by during the grand
prix and i can't find him in uscf but
he's up against uh doherty's board one
eli esrati who of course is a regular in
the grand prix series he was known as
desrat at the time if you remember that
and he's rated about uh it looks like
1400 or so so we'll see how we can do
against you know the the man of mystery
alex schimel fenning
so far we have a pretty strange opening
to be honest with you i'm not sure what
alex is doing here we of course have a
scandinavian so most common by far is to
capture this pawn um but instead it
looks like alex went for this move d3
and to my eyes black is simply going to
be
uh i mean at least fully equal if not
even slightly better here um you'll
sometimes see this type of idea if black
is committed to this move c5 then white
might be able to commit or might be able
to claim some kind of advantage here
right some kind of advantage you put
your king on c2
and your pieces can develop really
naturally and this pawn on c5 not really
where it wants to be you know you can't
develop your bishop out anymore and this
pawn is just a little bit uncomfortable
so in a position like this white would
have a better structure go like f3 you
can solidify your position but when
black still has this pawn on c7
absolutely no advantage here for white
in my opinion no reason to play like
this so so far so good for eli and it
looks like now we are caught up with the
players
and
let me make sure i didn't mess anything
up there
here we go yep e5 plate it looks like
the the board couldn't decide for a
second if it was e5 or e6 but e5 makes
the most sense to me and that's what's
on the board now i will say i'm not in
love with black's choice of developing
uh of the knights to their most natural
squares here so
uh very often you know these are the
correct squares for the knights but in
this case white is very clearly aiming
to play this move f3 solidifying this
pawn on e4 and that is just going to
make this knight look rather foolish on
the f6 square not really accomplishing
much on this square
best case it's going to come out to f4
but it could get there
from the e7 square anyways
so really all it's doing
is hampering black from getting that
same solid setup with f6
uh that being said you know not not a
big travesty for black at all he's
castled white's king still looks a
little bit foolish maybe this king will
come back to the f2 square i'm not so
comfortable leaving it hanging here
forever in fact i'm a little bit curious
why couldn't we just play czech and
bishop g2 on the last turn i think that
would have won a pawn but instead uh
white leaves the king on on d1 just with
impunity just absolutely no respect for
the discovered check from this bishop
now white has made a threat to this
bishop on a3 though oh and you do see
the players up there so that looks like
we were looking at the enterprise
doherty matchup before the show started
so you see eli there with the black
pieces and that is alex playing white
the man of mystery
himself and we still don't see alex move
his king off of d1 that was just g3 that
got played i think so now bishop h3 does
not win material but yes bishop g4 does
finally this tactic gets spotted and
this is going to be disaster for alex
this is just absolutely disaster here uh
once the king moves we take on f3 but
not only do we take f3 but we do it with
tempo right we're hitting the rook on h1
we're hitting the pawn on e4 and
eli is gonna be able to pick up a number
of pawns in the center here uh and that
number is two i know the number of pawns
so looking good for eli so far
um
we'll see what alex comes up with here
and we'll see how these these
complications work out and then maybe
we'll check in on on board too so king
e1 that was to be expected where else do
you put the king you want to connect
your rooks and it's a long path to
connect your rooks if you go to the
queen side so we see him come this way
now don't try to castle that's illegal
so instead rook h to f1 is definitely
legal and a better idea
and yeah that's pawn number two that's
pawn number two for eli he just snapped
on e4 but now i suspect alex has
something up his sleeve here he's
probably looking to capture this bishop
and after knight takes he wants to sneak
in with this rook here to f7 when all of
a sudden
uh what was once just a clean advantage
is now looking
slightly more complex
slightly more complex if i were black
here i would have seriously considered
this move bishop g2 and this might not
look like it makes the most sense at
first you know just rook f2 hits our
piece but then we have some nice
tactical ideas with this move knight to
g4 that would be hitting both the rook
and the bishop if you follow along here
and if white wants to take on f7 you're
going to lose your bishop with threats
and if you want to take on g2
now i can take back here
and again you're going to be in massive
massive trouble so bishop g2 i think
definitely was the way to go here and
then if white is a coward he'll just go
to g1 and then you can take and you
don't have to deal with this rook f7
stuff but very complex tactics for the
10 minutes that these players are
allowed
uh so how what how did the game continue
we did see 94 94 bishop c6 pawn c6 and i
can only assume now that's uh
oh i'm wrong i would have assumed
that white was aiming for the f7 pawn it
turns out he was going for the a7 pawn
this whole time
i'm not so comfortable about that pawn
though what about c5
okay not c5 but bishop c5 was played i
would have preferred to see this pawn
come here when we can think about
trapping this guy on a7 but bishop c5
instead we see another trade and then
this pawn on f7 is likely going to fall
as well
and if you're following along at home
doing the math i think that that would
bring white back to even material and it
is played on the board
and now that it's even material uh black
structure is simply much worse we talk
about pawn islands and chess uh and the
there are three pawn islands for black
maybe four depending on who you ask and
two pawn islands for white what's the
pawn island it's sort of your isolated
groups of pawns right so these two pawns
can interact with each other they can
defend each other but they cannot defend
this pawn in e5 similarly this pawn and
e5 can't help these c pawns and some
people would try to tell you that the c
pawns can't help each other so they're
also independent islands but i think
that that's all semantics
okay anyways though even material now
we're back in a very competitive game uh
rook d7 is played to defend along the
seventh rank looks like we have a trader
rooks here makes sense to me knight
takes and now it's all going to be about
a couple things here so whether or not
white can activate to target these
weaknesses and whether or not white can
make this past a pawn a utility
so he starts with this move b4 which
kind of strikes me as a little bit
strange if you want to push upon push
your a pawn get your a pawn up the board
make it a presence in the position make
black think about keeping a piece over
here to prevent its uh
prevent it from advancing even further
uh but honestly i would have preferred
to just see uh an activation of the
pieces here i don't think we need to
start pushing these pawns just yet i
want to see this rook come into the game
you know via some method here get to the
e file get to the f file start invading
and that's what black is focusing on
here so while white is pushing these
pawns you see black slowly but surely
bringing the pieces into the game
and
that activity is is very much going to
come in handy here going to come in
handy yeah more more pawn moves from
white you know people think you know
they know in the opening you shouldn't
make too many pawn moves you want to
activate your pieces but even in an end
game like this it can be really
important to activate your pieces as
quickly as you can otherwise you might
find yourself passively defending
king to b7 gets played now
and by pushing these pawns uh white has
gained some space but has sort of left
himself with this slightly weak pawn on
c3 you see black's knight is sort of
ready to jump into d5 at any moment here
and start targeting these guys so
alex sort of giving himself some
problems in this endgame i would have
liked to see just an activation of these
pieces once again
so a5 is going to force this knight to
to move from its b6 perch it comes out
to c4
perfectly reasonable square
i understand not wanting to go to d5 it
blocks the new rook doesn't feel the
most comfortable so the knight c4 very
decent move
and now it's on alex what will alex come
up with here
if i had the white pieces i'm taking a
look at this rook i'm saying wow that
rook is so much better than my stupid
rook on a1 let's trade it off just go
rook d1 get the rook off the board
wow instead a very strange move knight
to c1 i can't say i understand this it
has essentially just opened the door it
said please come in please work from d8
come into d2 come cause problems for me
i wanna
i want it i want it to happen he invited
the fox into the hen house as yasser
sarah one would say
that being said it's not all lost yet
you can still go rook a2 here and like i
said when your opponent's piece is
clearly better than yours you want to
trade it off this rook miles better than
the rook on a1 it's good to trade it off
so yeah we do see rook to a2 i support
this decision
and i don't know if i support the
slightly funky way where this knight c1
rook a2 concept came together but i
support the idea you want to trade the
rooks
definitely want to trade the rooks here
so after black trades the rook
uh rooks i'm not sure it's actually
hopeless for black at all i will say
because this pawn on e5 is still past
and i will repeat once again this knight
on c4 is a very active piece you know
white really allowed black to to get the
maximum activity in this position
that being said black doesn't like it uh
goes for rook to d5 instead
um a little bit of more chess info for
you here had we traded rooks we would be
in a pure king and knight versus king
and knight end game and
a world champion by the name of uh
botfinik had a rule about this he said
the evaluation of the end game with
knights is the same as the evaluation of
the endgame with only kings so if you
picture that these knights are off the
board we would have a king and pawn end
game that white is easily easily winning
because this is a protected pass pawn on
the queen side and this pawn is not
protected so maybe black knows this rule
knew to avoid the knight end game
and it has gone for this instead
okay we get knight to b3 after a6 king
a7
so a6 is a very double-edged move it's a
desirable move to push the pawn down
down the board further however it does
now leave behind its friends on b4 and
c3 so now white is going to have to be
careful not to let this pawn drop i
think what white has in mind is jumping
into the c5 square and then weaseling
around with this rook to sort of evict
this king from its nice blockading
square on a7
that being said that is uh ambitious as
we would say because now once again the
door is open for black to start getting
some counter play here you want to start
targeting these other guys these these
queen side pawns get rid of them all you
can
and then uh worst comes to worst maybe
you have to give up your knight for the
remaining pawn on the queen side but
that's not going to be so bad
and wow g5 instead this i think is
probably the the worst move black has
played uh
of the end game here
um g5 just doesn't really improve
black's position in any way black's not
going to win on the king's side with the
symmetrical structure black needed to
get active needed to take that moment
while he had it to activate his pieces
now
white's very simple plan of bringing
this rook uh on over to target these
pawns is going to be sort of difficult
difficult to stop if you're playing with
the black pieces here like how do you
how do you keep this rook from getting
in i'm not so sure you do
i'm not so sure you do keep this rook
from invading
now of course rook d3 no longer an
option the knight covers that square and
your rook on d5 is is looking a little
bit lost a little bit lost and confused
king e2 also seemed like a decent move
uh for white but i think knight c5 makes
the most sense right you don't really
want to block off your rook's access to
this f file that's that's how your rook
is getting active here you want to
invade on this f file and so king e2
sort of a step in the wrong direction if
that's your intention right you can't
get the rook to jump over the king
uh knight b6 by black and yeah this move
sort of indicates the the direction of
the game right all of a sudden you know
those past few moves black was moving
forward black was like yeah i'm i'm
invading knight c4 king b7 rook d2 my
pieces are moving forward and now it's
it's a total reversal right we saw the
rook retreat now the knight the king has
to will not retreat but the blockade the
pawn the knight retreats and it's it's
white now who is starting to advance
rook a2 knight b3 knight c5 knight e6
and the the activity sort of speaks for
itself here
um
knight to the e6 by the way is
actually a a fork that attacks two
things at the same time
black chooses to defend the g5 pawn with
this move e4
revealing the defense by the rook that
being said i think here
maybe
it was again time to try and get active
although it doesn't even work because
knight c7 threatens knight beef well it
doesn't threaten knight b5 we can just
take
uh because we have that square defended
yeah i think rook d3 again was the way
to go here you just have to get active
at all costs with black here passive
defense is rarely the way to go in the
end game you want to activate your
pieces make sure you get counter play
so to that to that effect i think again
we should be going rook d3 here we need
to activate our pieces
absolutely we need to
and i'm not sure what's uh what exactly
black is afraid of with rook to d3 it
looks like a very natural move i mean
you might you know lose
lose some fellow pawns along the way but
uh you want to sort of get after these
pawns
you want to get after them
and it looked like we saw a move there
yes rook d3 finally all right happy to
see it
happy to see it
all right and now it's on alex to solve
these problems again
and i think we've given this game quite
a lot of time here so we will check back
in on alex see how his conversion
process is going we'll see if uh
eli is able to cause some serious
problems and let's flip on over to board
one of the other match we have going on
here and this won't take long that's
checkmate in one
good job justin for edward jones and
there you actually do see resignation
and nick there another tournament
director for us is putting the kings on
the board uh signifying that uh black
has resigned that's that's checkmate how
did this happen
looks like a very simple tactic here d5
releases unleashes the bishop hits the
queen then we're going to come in this
way and and win the game as you saw
there
and yeah if you're just joining in the
chat thank you for checking this out
this is the corporate chess league this
is where uh different corporations in
the st louis area come to compete with
the best of the best chess players that
they can find in their organizations and
we are in the finals of our series of
our season actually for the spring
season so you're watching round one
right now we're flipping back and forth
uh now we're looking at board two of the
edward jones ascension match which is
also ending we're seeing all the
checkmates all at once that's queen to
d7 checkmate for alex curford so so far
so good for edward jones i think that
actually secures the match victory it
looks like their last second
substitution uh nayak devo has also won
his game on board four that's three out
of the four uh games for edward jones so
they are officially match victors
uh and they do have one game remaining
between maurice perry and steve evans
but we will let them sort that out
because we know the match victor over
there let's check back in on how
enterprise is doing against dirty
okay this one white is up two pieces i
like tomstack's chances for enterprise
now let's check in here on board three
looks like black is up a rook i like
ken's chances here so that's uh two
boards that look very good for
enterprise
and lastly on board four
looks like
enterprise again is up heavy heavy
materials so maybe our last game of
intrigue is going to be this one between
eli ezrati and alex schimelfening so
what happened here what happened rook d3
as i suggested love to see it by eli
rook c2 so now you see again the the
sort of the footing changes here again
now it's white who's passively defending
black who is getting active again the
knight jumps back to c4 where it belongs
king to e2 but that's not going to kick
the rook out and
we see all
the all the pieces flying now on on this
board actually all the pieces flying
okay knight b5 offers a trade of knights
and eli is hoping that this uh ensuing
rook end game is going to be drawn
i have to say though i'm not convinced
it looks like takes takes
check
takes
and
now the g pawn is almost certainly
going to fall
uh if you play rook c4
good idea but i don't think it's going
to be good enough if you move this guy i
take this guy
if you take this guy i take this guy and
two pawns versus none
and one pawn versus none is not going to
be a draw the two pawns tend to win
those end games so i think here after
knight b5 uh this should be a winning
endgame for
white and it looks like the players are
following along here except instead of
rook c4 he went rook c2 check king f3
rook c3 check
and i think that this is not going to
put up as much resistance as the other
line unfortunately all it's really
serving
to do is activate the king i would have
liked to see king g4 check and king g5
because again this end game is just
strictly uh going to be winning i think
instead we saw king e2
now that comes out to c4
and it's not so easy not so easy this
king has actually been pretty badly
misplaced here and i think we are
now heading towards a draw if you take
this guy
now you see why the king is badly placed
rook b2 check is going to knock your
king off the second rank and leave your
h-pawn
in the dust in the wind the h-pawn will
be the dust in the wind
okay king d3 instead if you want to try
here you can play this nasty looking
move h3 i sort of doubt it what's the
idea of this move the idea is if you get
checked you come back to the first he
tries to attack you now when you capture
you defend your pawn but i think at this
point it's already drawn you've wasted
too much time you've given up your pawn
too quickly and not to mention ideas
like g4 here which might just secure a
draw even more easily even more easily
uh what happened in the game though
let's follow along we saw black pushing
the king
and
oh wow okay so black did not try to go
after this h pawn but still this should
be a draw i think you need to go rook b2
and start coming this way and oh
my goodness uh the worst has happened
the worst has happened
the absolute worst has happened we
needed to go rook b2 check
and uh
well if here we can go check
and then
check and then we can escape with our
king that's what we needed to do instead
b4
actually just allows checkmate in one
that's that that's a sad end to the game
sad end of the game here with the black
king having no escape so
very valiant effort on the defensive end
here by eli asrati but could not get it
done he finally got active and then
uh sort of fell at at the final hurdles
here in this uh rather complex rook end
game rather complex i'm pretty sure this
one is winning i'm pretty sure this one
oh i'm sorry i'm pretty sure this one
is winning
um and indeed it is
but after uh some awkward moves by white
black actually should have been able to
just hold on to this g-pawn keep these
two pawns sort of at bay and then i
think black would have not really had
too many difficulties holding on here
but as always the clock situation is
gonna cause some problems and i believe
this is
um
maurice perry versus steve evans and
what's going on in this one we've got
another rook end game but black has an
extra knight and the pawns are
being vacuumed white holds on grips onto
that last pawn and 14 seconds for black
okay let's see it looks like we actually
do have a two second increment here
tonight i sort of forgot about that
uh ten plus two is the time control so
black should have enough time to get
this done
okay white switches to be behind the
past pawn but rook to h5 is going to
sort of ruin your day here and now king
f7 oh black just controls every square
on the board uh you can even let the
knight hang and he does let the knight
hang wow professional doesn't care about
the minor piece says i'm making a queen
you can deal with that
as you please
and uh nice technique on the pawn
promotion there showing some over the
board skills had the queen ready put the
queen on the promotion square did it all
legally
and
oh well that was a little bump bump of
the rook there by white but i i think at
this point this is this is all for show
and we do finally see
resignation
uh by by white close game close games
here today coming down to the wire
so with that result i think we actually
had two clean sweeps in the first round
ed edward jones went 4-0 against
ascension and enterprise went 4-0
against doherty so a little bit of a
surprising finish in my opinion to be
honest with you um i think ascension was
very much a contender in these finals
here and i think that they still are i
think that they have good chances to
take out enterprise and darty and if one
of those two teams can upset uh edward
jones we might see ascension in some
sort of tie break
but remains to be seen tough first round
for sure tough first round
uh and it looks like we have a little
bit of time before the next round so let
me catch up on the chat here uh instead
of rookie 2 why didn't he play king
takes e3 oh the knights defended that
i'm pretty sure we can check on that
position though
um
instead of king e2
sorry you instead of rookie two
oh king e3 well the rook does hang here
as well but okay this this would have
been good you're right you're right
you're right when you're right you're
right
um brock green is going to run this
tournament
brock green
is going to run this tournament is brock
green in this tournament he is but he
lost his first round so sad
so sad he's close though he's he's doing
well
he has the heart of a champion he can
will himself to victory brock green is
the fan favorite all right we'll have to
check in on brock's game uh next round
for sure then since he's the fan
favorite
um yeah it looks like an interesting
opening that he played this round but
then
yeah ran into some some trouble here had
to go rook eb1 as ugly as it looks to
defend everything here he goes down the
exchange
and then after
yeah after some trades here yeah good
game by by ken ma i mean ken's ken's a
professional he's been he's been doing
this for a while i've seen him in the
corporate chess league i think
since its inception if i'm not mistaken
since its inception ken ma has been out
here doing battle doing battle
that is substantially better than the
rook end games i tend to agree
um but yeah to go back to this game that
we spent so much time on i'll show one
more time
how i think black could have drawn this
game i think here
especially was the moment if you go rook
d3 here i think it's actually white who
starts to get into some serious trouble
like the only way you can defend this
pawn is with rook c2 and that of course
leaves your a6 pawn behind although
there is a tactic so you have to be
careful
um
but yeah rook c2 and
let's see i mean probably just e4
probably just e4
and
like i'm not so sure i'm not so sure
you're having fun here with uh with the
white pieces i get the feeling you're
not probably i over
overstated there and this is how the
game would end if these guys were
professionals
because i don't think black has a lot to
play for tough to get to the second rank
if you can't get to the second rank
tough to say you're playing for an
advantage
um but yeah very very
complex game here very complicated and
competitive game probably the most
competitive game of the first round i
would say
let's check in let's see what justin
managed to do against steve gilmore how
did he take out ascension's board one oh
it was with a little bit of an opening
idea here little danger in the opening
so i talk about this idea a lot whenever
i'm teaching chess it seems really
counter-intuitive that everybody in
chess history is playing openings like
the queen's gambit declined now why is
that counterintuitive well it blocks
your bishop in behind your pawn chain
you see it's stuck here looks like a bad
bishop but there are some very good
reasons why this happens and that is
because if you develop this bishop early
you very often run into light squared
issues on your queen site here you see
this is a simple double attack and black
cannot defend both both pawns so after
c6
drops this pawn on b7 drops this pawn on
c6 drops this pawn on d5
and that's going to be a winning opening
advantage
uh what's the tourney format a great
question so if you're just joining and
you missed the intro to the show here
tonight it is a round robin between our
four different teams all that counts
here tonight is the match points if you
win the match you get a point if you tr
uh if you draw your match you get a half
point
and it's just a
winner take all if you end the round
robin with the most match points you are
our corporate chess league champions
if there is a tie after the round robin
we go straight to armageddon playoffs
right to armageddon playoffs so if it's
a two-way tie
each team selects one player to
represent their entire team all their
hopes and dreams will be riding on one
player uh and the higher seeded team
would get to select their color in the
armageddon uh and that's that's it that
determines the winner
now what does the winner get besides you
know honor and glory well they get their
team's name uh etched into uh the
corporate chess league uh official board
that is sort of the running trophy you
see it there edward jones are winners
last year you see the whole team there
uh alex and vishal
notable uh competitors on the team
vishal of course not joining the edward
jones team this year sorely missed but
the dream is still alive for edward
jones they won their first round hoping
to repeat hoping to win i believe
their fourth
their fourth edition of the corporate
chess league i think they are three time
champions
uh i might be wrong in that it might
only be two but i get the feeling it's
three by now
uh so it could be going for four could
be going for three nobody knows but all
i know is that uh it's gonna be tough
enterprise of course the only other team
to win the corporate chess league aside
from edward jones and as always they're
looking to put up a fight
uh and it looks like now we do have the
players uh settling in in the tournament
hall
uh and as i switch over to round two uh
let's see what we've got going on here
so we are going to have ascension versus
enterprise which is a match you're going
to want to keep an eye on and it is
going to be edward jones against
dougherty uh dougherty always going to
be the underdogs in this final but we
saw a very tough showing by eli israe on
their board one in
that first round there and if they show
that that that kind of fight
throughout the remainder of this event i
wouldn't be surprised to see them uh get
a match uh tie or even a match victory
against these these other teams
that being said i do think we want to
keep an eye on this ascension enterprise
match because i think again ascension
definitely the dark horse of the
tournament not at all a favorite in the
tournament but they have a very
competitive team i've seen them take
points off of these other teams and i i
am sort of cheering for them to at least
put some points up on the scoreboard
here tonight
uh so with that it looks like the round
is getting underway i want to follow uh
tom schofbuck
in round one against tom stack it's the
battle of the toms it's the battle of
the toms we'll see who comes out
victorious here uh ascension or
enterprise how can we not follow the
battle of the toms
uh ken is very strong but you need to
crack a few eggs to make an omelette i
agree i agree
and yeah mishra making a good point it's
all fun and games until someone hires uh
levon and fabi on a 10-day contract this
is this is true i wouldn't be i wouldn't
put it past these teams wouldn't put it
past these teams in a very interesting
opening by uh tom shofbuck with c5 here
so i used to do this all the time when i
was actually sort of a beginner i
thought it made a whole lot of sense to
stop moves like bishop d6 and just sort
of cramp my opponent but as i've grown
and matured a little bit in chess i've
sort of come to realize that this is
just a little bit too far if black comes
after these pawns right away this is not
going to be tenable not tenable at all
for white these pawns are going to fall
apart and i think we do see black going
for something similar although he did
delay it by just a few moments here so i
would have liked to see him do it
immediately
now it is still the correct idea for
black to go for this it's not going to
be quite as strong oh and what does this
move queen a4 i was going to say it's
not quite as strong because white can
just play a3
and
thanks to white having developed the
queen side uh this a pawn is not pinned
you can compare that with this line that
i was showing
where now if you go a3 big trouble for
you your rook is undefended not
connected to your queen and black just
wins
so i would have liked to go for it
immediately just to you know really show
white you cannot hold everything
together but now instead we see white
going for some very active ideas here
queen a4 uh putting the counter pin onto
black and then after bishop b7 getting
out of it threatening once again a takes
b
b5 right away by tom shafbuk and this is
just a a straight winning attempt he's
just trying to to win out of the opening
trying to crush his opponent so this is
a very very scary move to deal with if
you
uh try to take c5 of course white's
going to take c6 and that's game over
right there
and if you try to take b5 let's see what
tom has in mind here you could make an
argument for bishop takes but i don't
think this would work out quite as well
for you i do think black is going to
have time to capture on c5 so it must be
knight takes is his intention with
knight c7 coming on tap
and now what's what's happening
happening next is sort of anybody's
guess anybody's guess i would assume
bishop c6 has to be played
and after that it's it's a little bit
crazy i don't think we have knight c7 i
don't think we
have knight d6 maybe we do have knight
d6 but it's complicated i don't know i
want to see what happens in this game
and bishop b5 was his intention but i do
not believe in this move i simply don't
believe in this bishop b5 idea maybe
knight b5 wasn't working either with
this bishop c6 idea but after bishop b5
i think black is just going to capture
this pawn on c5 and be a pawn to the
good not only is he a pawn to the good
but he's fully developed castling next
turn and then this knight is free then
it can come to b6 start harassing these
white pieces start pushing them back get
fully developed get back into the game
and the players are following this line
now we see b takes c and d takes c on
the board and i believe
uh
that must be bishop takes c5 on the
board as well yeah uh all the moves
played
ah so so far so good in the battle of
the thomas for black uh tom schaffer
putting up uh quite a lot of pressure
early on uh turning up the heat
but so far the other tom tom stack has
been able to respond coolly and calmly
he's developed all his pieces now he
just needs to castle his king which has
the nice bonus of sidestepping this
knight to e5 threat and after castles i
see no reason why white has any
compensation for this extra pawn
and that black has has gained
okay so in the battle of the toms uh we
are gonna see a good fight but tom stack
has taken the lead we already have a
result in this game
wow an eight move game mike eberle for
eberly from ascension has already gone
down to the classic d4 d5 tactic losing
a piece and then bam
that's checkmate
not a great game by mike i'm sure he
wishes he he had that one back
uh meanwhile let's check in on fan
favorite brock green let's see what's
going on in this game we have knight f3
f5 uh
sort of weird to respond to knight f3
with a dutch but if you like the dutch
then it makes sense i guess and we get
f5 e5 now as well in a very very strange
position is already developing bishop e7
okay castles castles
and f4 wow black is just pushing pushing
pushing pushing we see an opening of the
f file here for both players
and white has this slightly soft
structure going on with h3g3
not super easy to keep track of all
these weaknesses that being said this
bishop on g2 is going to help out it's
going to help defend the king quite a
bit
this bishop 27 i wouldn't call it a
great piece for black but the good news
is it's sort of out of the way it leaves
the door open for this queen to come in
and join the attack on the king side and
it is going to be targeting some useful
squares that white might have liked to
have control over so we see king h2 now
queen g6 would add another attacker to
that g3 pawn i assume brock is planning
to play this move queen to e1 to keep it
all under control the one thing brock
absolutely should not do is play this
maybe tempting looking move g4 you all
you accomplish with this is you kick the
knight into the fantastic f4 square you
do not want to see this knight on f4 you
do not want to see this
that being said king h2 in black is in
the tank here steve uh for edward jones
taking his time thinking over this queen
g6 idea i'm sure he's spotted this queen
to e1 defense and he's thinking about
what he what he can do about it what do
you want to do about queen to e1 what's
the idea
in the meantime black also has other
moves to consider you can just play a
move like queen or bishop e6 get your
rooks sort of more connected consider
going after the h pawn a little bit
lots of things to do here with with
black lots of ideas
and it looked like he was reaching for a
piece but he didn't quite find it didn't
quite find it
what's white's plan here well for one
thing white has slightly misplaced their
their pieces especially this bishop on
b2 this piece just does not make sense
here like if if you wanted to have this
bishop on b2 you would like sort of try
to combine it with some sort of d4 to
open up this diagonal but i think d4 is
just always going to be a sort of
incorrect idea here you know you don't
leave yourself with this e pawn you
especially don't want to give black this
e5 square for one of his pieces so i
think what white needs to do is uh
defend the king's side a little bit play
some awkward moves queen e1 rook d1 then
i want to bring this bishop just back to
c1 to be honest this bishop belongs here
it needs to guard the f4 square needs to
guard the g5 square we can reroute our
knight to some tempting looking squares
ourselves and i think that that is how
uh how white needs to
improve the pieces
sometimes you know it's it's wrong to
over justify your previous play you
don't just because you stuck your bishop
on b2 doesn't mean you need to base your
entire game around it sometimes it's
better just to say okay i was wrong the
bishop belongs on this diagonal let me
move it back and so i think that's the
the right way to go here
uh that being said uh brock disagrees
with me he says i know what i'm doing i
put my bishop here for a reason i want
to go d4 and open up this diagonal
so i really don't like this this way of
playing though for for white we see
this capture happen on d4 now white is
left with this isolated e pawn
and i think black is going to be able to
keep control over the e5 square and if
black does manage to keep control over
e5 then i think black is is simply
better in this position just bishop f6
here you do not want to allow white to
push e5 as well then white's play would
make quite a bit of sense
uh and if black can can consolidate here
i think white is
very much on the worst end of things
very much on the worst end of things
bishop f6 ah and you mentioned a nice
tactical idea here you were looking at
queen g6 still
still angling for this g3 pawn and if
queen to e1 you wanted to take i do
think white would have knight takes
there but i do agree that that would
highlight some of the awkwardness in in
black's position or in white's position
still and said the natural idea bishop
f6 did come through and we just see this
knight retreat back to f6
uh i guess you can technically play e5
now and maybe not just technically maybe
this is just a very good move um
for white
maybe it's all coming together for mr
green we see e5
and it's i mean it's it's
um
no lead pipe in the conservatory but
it's certainly going to give steve a
headache uh how do you like that one
okay
let's check back in on tom shoftbook see
how he's doing in his game
um
what happened what happened okay we saw
this b5 move we saw black capture here
on c5 go up the pawn knight b6 just like
i mentioned and now we see black just uh
activating the pieces so i am not in
love with this awkward placement of all
sort of five of these pieces on the
queen side it feels like there might be
a tactic here and white tries to find it
goes a3
now bishop g5
and yeah i think already some some
tactics are sort of in the air here sort
of takes you cannot take with the queen
you would have to take like this
and maybe there's just no good
discoveries here with the bishop but we
can
sort of i don't know it looks weird
right it looks like uh black has a lot
of pieces hanging maybe just bishop e2
if you take my knight i take your bishop
looks like white was getting some play
here and said bishop h4 bishop b7 and
now captures okay i don't really think
that makes any sense and now bishop d3
after the rook is attacked
yeah it looks like tom schofbuk found a
lot of the ideas but just it all
happened in the wrong order for him it
all happened in the wrong order that
being said bishop a1 knight b6 is our
current position
and i guess what uh tom shaft book is
saying is if you save your bishop i'll
take your rook but i do think there were
some clever ideas like rook to c3 here
that would have made white's life
very very difficult if you go
queen b5 i go bishop c6
and i don't know could have been
interesting instead we end back uh sort
of where we started with black being up
a clean pawn but just upon no extra
exchange sort of uh white gets away with
one there with allowing bishop takes a1
uh white now has an idea it would seem
playing for mate but unfortunately i
think black is going to be able to find
a nice solid setup if you put these
pawns on g6 and h5 very difficult here
for for white to break through gonna be
very difficult
go
e-h-i
who's e-h-i
i'm sorry i don't know ehi
bishop a6 so this sort of preempts this
queen d3 idea also takes advantage of
the fact that rook c1 is not currently
possible so white doesn't really have a
good square to move the rook to neither
of these squares look particularly
impressive
and after this i would expect you know
queen c4 rook c8 get the rest of the
pieces involved and it should still be
smooth sailing for um
for black enterprise oh that's john
hello john i didn't know ehi was like uh
enterprise
um
it's coming together for brock all right
we'll check back in on brock
it looked good when we last left it and
oh my god where did all the pieces go
where did all the pieces go so we saw
this and then knight c4 i really think
this e5 move would have been awkward for
black to deal with but knight c4 instead
we get this awkward-looking structure
but if white can just get this one move
through then life is going to be good so
black immediately puts the kybasha on
that plays queen e5 we get knight to d7
and now some rooks get traded queen f3
queen f5 and now after takes takes we do
get this awkward end game
where you know you might think it's all
coming together for brock he's got this
nice king side majority which could even
get mobile if you get g5 and f6 at some
moment but the downside is there are a
lot of weaknesses over here on the queen
side you know just picture for a moment
knight b4 landing on the board how are
you defending any of your
weaknesses um instead of using the
knight to attack though we do see uh
steve here is bringing in the king
trying to play king c3 king c2 type
ideas
on the one hand this does seem desirable
but on the other hand i am a little bit
wary of leaving my my little knight over
here uh in charge of stopping all the
past pawns knight's sort of notorious
for not being so good at stopping past
pawns
and that is what brock is is counting on
here we see g5 i'm actually very
interested to see how this game is is
gonna pan out because i can very much
see this going uh going brock's way so
h6 must be the idea
must be the idea and then if brock can
find uh one tricky move here i think he
might actually be in business so h6 what
i don't think brock should do is capture
that pawn because then
after f6 you're simply going to see
knight d7
and knight f8 and now it's going to take
you a lot of time to come kick this
night out and in that time you're going
to see
uh black pushing down the board as well
uh what i think he should go for is
maybe this sort of strange-looking move
f6
f6 i think was was a game ender here i
think f6 was
was winning in fact if you take me on g5
i'm not going to take you back i'm going
to take you on g7
next thing you know big trouble
big trouble
big big trouble how do you stop this
pawn
and if you take me on f6 i take you on
h6 and again big big trouble so i think
that this was brock's moment if he found
this nice move f6 i think the game was
in hand it looks like he did go for the
wrong idea though he took on h6 and now
they followed down the the line that i
was saying rather than play knight f8
though it looks like black went with
king d4 just coming back and this pawn
is is not long for this world anymore so
brock had his moment he had his moment
he had f6 there and then um
and then i think he was just winning but
instead
for this slightly inaccurate idea now
black is back in time to stop the pawn
not only stop the pawn but win the pawn
and once this pawn dies
white is in for a bumpy ride to say the
least definitely a bumpy ride okay i
think you should not take that guy
if you don't take that guy i think you
do win this game um takes on c4 that is
nothing if not bold i would see the
spawn on f7 i would say i want to kill
that pawn as soon as i can and i would
capture it immediately um but that was
was not played um
now it's it's interesting again 95 king
e6 you can't take the bishop you can't
take the pawn
you can't play d5 because it's defending
your knights is white winning is white
winning again
i think white might be winning again it
might be coming up brock here uh through
some sort of
uh
very strange
set of circumstances here so
knight d5 so he's just saying yeah i'm
gonna go king f8 here and that's how i'm
stopping you from queening your pawn
okay king to d7 was was optimistic i
think black always has this move king f8
um
and it should in fact be played
but
yeah brock definitely in there he's he's
in the fight
hello to jacob in the chat okay so we
can take this d6 pawn now and yeah this
moment here this is one to look back on
if you're steve evans and you you can
take this c pawn or you can just get rid
of this f pawn that's one move away from
queening like get get rid of the guy
that's gonna end you end the game
um instead we're here black is not up
upon it's even material um and if i'm
white i'm thinking about ways i can sort
of worm my way in here try and get after
these pawns
knight c7 i do not like that by steve
this knight was doing a great job
keeping that king out now the king gets
in these pawns are collapsing knight f7
is 10 moves too late should have done
that 10 moves ago i take your pawn i
come back boom boom boom boom boom
that's gonna end the game and here we
switch to the live view looks like white
went after the c pawn instead but is
still winning this race with time to
spare
look at him go like four or i guess only
like two moves ahead of black that's
going to be an extra queen
and i rate his technique 10 out of 10
again for promoting the pawn well done
by these players
um and now queen h3 no queen g8 okay
that's slightly strange but
that'll get the job done yeah queen g1
very carefully
and yeah just queen h2 just go queen h2
just make sure the pawn can't move
and then you never lose and that's
resignation by steve huge win by brock
green for dougherty and what is this is
this gonna be
the upset of of the century wait a
second what's happening here
what's happening doherty one on board
four just one on board three we saw
chris sell beating alex carford on board
two and that is an upset that is an
upset dirty nobody thought they would be
in this match nobody thought they would
be winning this final
but that is three straight wins for
doherty against edward jones they
knock the leaders down a peg
in the meantime what's going on with our
other leaders enterprise they won on
board four they lost on board three
maurice perry for ascension getting it
done so now these games these remaining
games are very relevant and as we switch
back to the battle of the toms
bam rook c3 not a moment too soon and
that is going to be an extra queen now
for tom stack all he has to do is get
rid of this pawn not going to be a
problem for him this pawn is going
nowhere impossible to uh to defend it
and that's an extra queen
so then it comes down to board one
what's going on here oh and it looks
like steve gilmore for ascension is
easily winning as long as he doesn't
make a queen okay good job this
is stalemate so don't do that instead
knight d3 much better idea and now we
can queen safely with check and that is
the end of the game that is the end of
the game
uh steve gilmore gets it done gets it
done
so with that provided black wins this
game uh provided tom stack wins this
game for enterprise i believe
that makes enterprise
our sole leaders with one and a half out
of two
they would tie this match with ascension
if tomstack can get the job done here
and that after king g4 is the loss of
black's uh last major piece so i i can
only assume tomstack is going to be able
to win
can only assume
yeah everybody in the chat is a brock
fan
brock the fan favorite for sure okay
um not much left to see in this game
and it is our last game so i will say
justin beckstead ford one for edward
jones did win his game but it was all
for knotts uh because the lower three
boards for edward jones all lost
losing it to dougherty
tough second round for them
uh so with these standings now
uh again assuming tomstack can win this
game assuming stomp tom can can get the
job done here against tom
we're going to have
one interesting final round of course in
the final round
uh our leader
uh enterprise
is taking on edward jones and in the
meantime dardy is taking on ascension
so okay king f6 that
was not made in one but not still made
as well
queen g5
and the game
let's do it there it is it's on the
board
he hits his clock both players still
looking at the board
it is checkmate though
it it is checkmate and
now
they're still looking okay now they're
talking about the game all right the
game's over checkmate has been declared
and that ends our second round
so
uh
what a round that was i did not expect
already to come back with the the huge
upset against edward jones edward jones
not the number one seed but i think they
might have shown up with the strongest
team here tonight uh of course
enterprise and edward jones both missing
some key parts of their team tonight not
everybody could make it out
but i think edward jones by raiding at
least has the strongest team uh being
fielded here tonight and bam just dirty
just getting it done just getting it
done
upsetting edward jones and giving us
quite a lot to talk about in the the
final round here
so again
one round to go third round and we are
going to see enterprise versus edward
jones enterprise leading the field with
one and a half uh edward jones in second
place with one point and now doherty
also in second place with a point so we
very much could see playoffs if darty
wins in the final round they will have
two points
and they are uh
they they would make the playoffs
provided enterprise does not win their
match uh so again if darty wins against
ascension they're in the playoffs unless
enterprise wins their match if
enterprise wins this last round nobody
can stop them they're in charge of their
own destiny here of course being up a
half point going into the last round
will do that for you
so
uh
one round to go looking forward to it
and i think i just heard that there's
going to be a little bit of a longer
break between the second and third round
i'm not sure what i just heard yeah but
uh 20 minute break it looks like so
we'll stick on we'll take a look at some
of
uh some of these games that we we didn't
keep an eye on here so we saw a fan
favorite
um
justin beckstead uh win or sorry not fan
favorite justin buckstead although the
fans do love justin bexted as well fan
favorite uh
brock green winning his game in
controversial style we learned a little
bit about pawn end games there but i
wanted to check in on justin beck's dead
against eli asrati the one game edward
jones did win in the second round here
um i think justin may be our highest
rated player in the events
again i'm not sure what alex's rating is
but justin i believe is like uh 1650
1700 over the board and he's around 1900
i think i've seen him over two thousand
um in
uh online chess online chess
so let's check in here let's see what he
managed to do against eli israe we saw
d4 d5 c4 e6
and a queen's gambit declined so far so
normal and knight c6 so this one is a
little bit odd a little bit strange here
normally in these queens pawn openings
you don't want to block in your c pawn
this pawn is very useful either in
defensive role with c6 or in a more
offensive role with c5 challenging your
opponent's center with knight to c6 you
are still challenging the center but
after this move e3 you see that it's
never really going to be enough you sort
of need the c pawn here to apply more
pressure in tandem with the knight as
white is doing on the other side so
knight to c6 not the most normal move
but uh
i'm not going to hold it against him we
saw castles rook c1 bishop comes back
we exchange on d5 exchange on e7 and now
bishop d3
both players sort of finishing
development we see castles bishop b7
and e4 and the the sad fact of the
matter here is black is never quite
going to be equal as long as white has
this extra space in the center whenever
you play an opening that sort of gives
up uh the central duo allows your
opponent to take the central space uh
it's an absolute necessity to eventually
challenge the center with a move like c5
or a move like e5 if you don't get
either of these moves then you're just
going to be in big trouble
so let's see if that's what happened in
this game we saw e4 f6 a3 knight back to
c6 bishop a2
queen to d6
and
white pushes through in the center okay
yeah once this pawn's on d5 it's looking
tough we saw a sort of weird way to
exchange the pieces uh with rookie six
and then rook d1 but this e6 pawn is
definitely a force to be reckoned with
here okay knight h4
and it
looks sort of sad for black looks sort
of sad this pawn definitely more of an
asset than a weakness it looks
overextended but it's just sort of
hampering black's entire position
and then what what is what is this why
did we not take the piece back there
there's a rule in chess that i like to
talk about called when my opponent takes
my pieces i try to take his pieces back
and so i definitely think that that's a
good one here uh the rule was not
followed uh justin took eli's pieces and
eli just didn't take them back just take
the pieces back
they're worth taking they're valuable
um instead we get this and look at those
pieces look at look at look at the
perfect diamond around the rook uh the
rook escapes but white gets a queen and
then we see it fork and that's how
justin managed to win on board one
okay what else happened in this round
how did alex go down uh in the last
round that was played and hello jacob do
you need to talk to the producer ben
simon oh no i'm going to ask you a
question okay what would you do what's
up jacob second commentator i joined you
guys
think you need to talk to the producer
ben simon jacob
i'm on air okay alex uh plays d4 knight
f6 e3 d5 bishop d3
and we get a pretty normal setup here
okay f4 out of the opening by alex uh
so this is a really interesting idea
here so black took a sort of unorthodox
setup by bringing this bishop to g7 uh
against white's setup here so why is
this unorthodox well white has a very
solid setup with this pawn on d4 and
unless black is able to open up this
diagonal bishop's not really going to
make a lot of sense there so maybe alex
looked to take advantage of that with
this move f4 sort of anticipating that
black's plan might revolve around
something just to put some sort of
nonsense moves on the board
might revolve around playing
a move like e5 in in the future
something like this trying to open up
this diagonal make this make bishop make
sense
so perhaps anticipating that he goes
with f4 and then develops with knight f3
it looks like this was a solid uh way of
thinking because black continued to play
rook e8 although it might not make as
much sense anymore we go b6 b3 bishop b7
and let's see
so far so normal it looks like alex got
a little bit of an opening edge but then
bam black breaks through with e5 anyways
this f pawn did not stop black's uh
dreams and then all of the central
tension and ooh
that one is gonna hurt this knight on f4
is a monster and then bishop h6 to rub
salt on the wound doesn't even take on
d3 activates instead and that's a check
and the loss of a queen and i assume
that that was the the history of that
game that was it
rook f7 gets played in this game but
chris does not care mate and two i don't
want your stupid rook
i don't want your stupid rook
um
last round bring out the full crew yeah
so i had to direct him to our producer
because we don't have the microphones
for it set up unfortunately uh we would
love the special guest
but uh
don't have the mics hooked up
uh so with that i think we just have a
few more minutes here before our last
round is going to get underway uh who
haven't we heard from today who haven't
we heard from i think we've checked in
on most people maybe we haven't seen
much from darren dowler against mike uh
oh no we did see the skin this was the
eight move game let's check back in on
ken ma so ken went down in this round
against maurice perry let's check the
winner's point of view
um
we got a king's pawn opening and a quick
d3 g3 so i like this this type of idea
for rapid chess especially sort of
offbeat and if your opponent doesn't
respond quickly in the center then
things can sort of get out of hand you
get castle you get f4 ideas going but
black responded correctly with an early
d5 and this is a great idea to just keep
in mind if you ever play an e4 e5
opening and you find yourself in
against an opponent who's doing
something that seems sort of irrelevant
to the center like you know like a move
like g3 just slow and not controlling
the center very very often it's going to
be in your best interest to break
through with d5 and once you do this
it's hard to be any worse right
any slow plans are just not gonna work
and so opening up the position with d5
is normally good um that being said i've
been told that it looks like the games
are about to begin so let's check back
in yeah we see all the players at their
boards
and uh mike cummer patrolling again
making sure we're ready to go and what a
last round this is going to be we're
definitely going to need to follow this
enterprise edward jones match because
it's kind of for all the marbles it's
for all the marbles here doherty of
course has a chance to make the playoffs
as well if they win their match but
enterprise could end the night in this
round all they need to do is win this
match and they are your 2022 spring
champions
champions
and games are underway all right let's
check in on alex schimel fenning on
board one against ed uh justin beckstead
for edward jones justin again i think is
our highest ranked player highest rated
player in the tournament and we have
ourselves a french defense
wow knight c3 knight f6
f3
what is f3 i don't know this move at all
i don't think i've ever seen this move
in my entire life of course after knight
f6 two common moves you go bishop g5
pinning this knight threatening e5 or
you just go e5 make that knight move
again make it feel dumb and then you can
start taking over the center
f3 not a move i'm at all familiar with
black quickly played c5 which i think
is the most sensible way to continue
here
um
white didn't play an active move didn't
make any threats so you might as well go
after his center so c5 bishop e3 now
knight c6 continues to pile on the
pressure uh don't even think about
snatching this pawn d4 is gonna be a
cold shower uh winning a piece so we got
bishop b5 instead and now it's up to
justin what he wants to do
what to do
justin he goes queen b6 okay keeping the
pressure up
now i guess you can think about
snatching this pawn
and
i still don't think it's a good idea
though so probably just the simpler uh
knight g to e2 might be what uh
what white has in mind that being said
this this cannot be good for for white
this just simply cannot be good this
move f3 is not really a normal plan here
at all just not really a normal plan
hello uh josue jose jose ramirez thank
you for joining
this of course is the corporate chess
league finals and it's the last round of
the finals two this is where all the
action is happening okay knight ge2 so
what's going on here for black what
happens if we take all the guys i take
you
you take me i guess with the bishop and
then i feel dumb because my knight is
pinned and i can't capture so what if i
try harder what if i go a6 and i say
look at your dumb bishop move your dumb
bishop unpin me i want to take your guys
get out of my face i guess white might
be intending
to back up with bishop a4 because i
really don't think it's in your best
interest to take on c6 here these
structures tend to be good for
black this is a fork but not really i
can get out of it with check and take
your bishop or take your knight
depending on what you do
um
so bishop c6 can't be the idea so i
really like this move a6 sort of forcing
white's hand
instead though black goes bishop d7
which has a similar sort of plan just
unpinning the knight still going for
these ideas in the center but a6 just
seemed a little bit more forcing to me a
little bit more forcing
um that being said
a pretty good start for justin
now it's up to alex to deal with these
problems
maybe alex just wants to blow everything
up maybe he's just gonna say all right
i'm gonna take everywhere we're gonna
trade some pieces and i won't be worse
although i'm not sure that that won't be
worse thing is is actually going to be
true uh like i said i think edward jones
uh has one of the the strongest uh rated
teams here in the finals but maybe alex
is thinking that his lower boards are
are going to be able to carry him
through the match all he needs to do is
get away with a draw against justin who
again i believe is the top seed
e5 was alex's choice and then castles
now the only thing about this is
that it doesn't work tactically
that's not the only thing about this
even if it works tactically white
obviously wants to play f4 here to shore
up the center defend everything more
thoroughly but if you want to play f4
here that really begs the question why
was f3 played that's just going to be a
waste of a tempo
so what was that i was saying about not
working tactically of course black has
knight e5 here
on
discovering this attack on the bishop on
b5 if you take my knight i take your
bishop if you take my bishop i take back
with my knight saving it from the threat
of capture what did black do black just
took on d4 instead we got knight takes
d4 and then bishop c5 different way of
going about things still looks very
promising for black
now if you go knight takes i of course
take with check before i recapture
i do think white is going to be able to
just barely hold on to all the pieces
though if we give up our bishop here we
can play bishop take c6 then no matter
how we recapture queen to d2 everything
is defended just enough times you can
think about taking on b2 but i'm not so
sure that you want to i can get very
very active bring my rook to any number
of squares and you might regret uh
snatching my pawn you might not regret
it you might have bishop b4 you might
make my day difficult too but uh
you might you might not be so so happy
in fact knight b5 here i'm already sort
of curious i guess i have bishop e3
never mind uh complicated stuff though
complicated stuff instead we saw bishop
c5 and then what did white choose to do
white played knight a4
and wait a second i forgot about this
but
um i've seen this story before believe
it or not these are some complicated
tactics but black should actually be
significantly better after the move
bishop takes d4
is black capable of playing this movie
is bishop takes d4 on the board knight
b6 and we are gonna see a full three
pieces for the queen for black and that
is actually kind of close to a winning
advantage of course three pieces worth
nine points total the queen also worth
nine points total
but it's sort of a different kind of
nine points you know if you have three
pieces you can get them coordinated then
you're gonna be off to off and running
you're gonna be off to the races you're
gonna be dominating a queen uh just
having three attackers on anything
having the ability to attack something
three times is so so so valuable
compared to the one uh the one queen
now we do see this move f4 again sort of
pointing out why this opening doesn't
make so much sense why did you put your
pawn on f3 if you're gonna put it on f4
anyways
uh was it really worth it to delay it
i'm not so sure now knight g to e7 and
we are definitely sticking with this
game three pieces for the queen what a
show for the final round on board one
what a show
the knight comes back out to e7 this
makes a ton of sense
uh now what do you want to do with the
queen here well there's a few things
that you can try to do to make uh life
difficult for the pieces number one you
don't want to let them get coordinated
so for example after knight five you see
how all the pieces are sort of working
together the dark squared bishop the
knights all attacking similar squares
sort of threatening to invade in the
meantime this bishop trying to come out
and work on the other long diagonal you
don't want to let that happen so if i
had the white pieces here i would be
looking to play things like g4 in
response to knight to f5 i would even
play g4 here making sure that knight
doesn't get the chance to land on f5
i'm gonna be looking to play things like
c3 trying to keep this knight out of d4
um looking to do sort of all of these
things although of course all my moves
are still blundering knight e5 this is
still a tactic in the position that i
don't think either player is noticing
but that's okay
what i wouldn't do is this move c4
because what does c4 do it's actually
going to be opening up more
squares for these pieces like let's say
takes takes um
maybe knight a5
where does my bishop go next thing you
know
bishop c6 would be bad but knight to d5
and like you see again
my pieces are starting to get
coordinated right pieces are starting to
get coordinated
that's what you want to avoid instead a6
was played and now maybe black is
thinking about taking on on c4 black
might also just be wary of opening
things up before he gets castled but
there's really no way for white to
prevent castles here and i don't think
black is ever going to be in danger
having three pieces for the queen gives
you a lot of attackers but also gives
you a lot of defenders so life is really
really just nice here for uh for black
uh d take c4 is played i think it's best
and yeah but the more i look at it the
more i think that uh black is just close
to winning here let me see what an
engine says i'm just curious yeah minus
four pretty good pretty good for black
so let's check in on board two then for
this match up we have
uh tom stack for enterprise and alex
kurford for edward jones and alex going
for some redemption here looks like he
won some material looks like he found a
nice knight takes f3 tactic with bishop
takes c3 to follow that forks the rooks
bam picking up an exchange picking up
the e4 pawn doubling on the e file
rookie two next checkmate threats
incoming and that looks good for alex so
uh no matter what happens on board one
looks like board two is going well
for uh for edward jones we saw this move
queen f6 now and that is sort of another
fork uh white i guess needs to play rook
f1 otherwise it's big big trouble
and then
no no say it isn't so bishop g3 did this
get played
did this get played
bam queen a1 it did happen it did happen
okay that's victory for alex now picks
up a rook on a1 nobody saw that it was
attacked uh well alex did but tom never
saw that it was attacked and
unfortunately loses a rook there now
this game between steve and ken ma is
only on move 14. how did we get here we
had a two nights caro
uh with bishop g4 wow so far big theory
by the players big big theory well
massive theory
these guys did their homework he knew
all the way to g4 after knight bd7
that's wild that's more caracon theory
than i know
takes on e4 not the most normal it looks
like h6 or g6 is what they tend to do
i'm trying to stop you know some g5
threats of course here if you go g5 i'm
gonna come knight h5 and here if you go
g5 i'm just gonna take you and you're
gonna feel dumb uh instead d takes e4 d
takes e4 was played and now after bishop
b7 yeah looks like g5 is the idea and
well steve just knows everything here he
knew the g5 idea he executed the g5 idea
and now black's pieces are going to be
very very awkward expands out with f4
gets castled comes through with f5 and
oh my god it's just so sad for ken
and wow if
if i ever get paired against steve evans
i am
not playing into this line of the caro
khan
this guy knows everything how did he
know everything here that was wild so
also looking good for edward jones here
although not nearly as good as those
other two boards this is just a massive
opening advantage uh steve i can i'm
impressed that was a lot of stuff to
know about this line in the caro con
and last but not least what's going on
on board four oh it's a mess it's what
is this structure what is this pawn
doing here i don't know but knight f4 is
on the board
looks like white is a couple bonds to
the good one pawn up one pawn up
hold on
yep i counted one pawn up looks good for
white these pawns of course also going
to be pretty big weaknesses
and white is always going to be
threatening to push through with d5
which is going to spell disaster if d5
ever happens black is is busted so
edward jones looks to be making a great
recovery on
uh
on uh against the the current leaders
enterprise so that's gonna make our
second match uh actually really really
important if doherty is able to defeat
ascension we would go to playoffs we
would have edward jones versus doherty
if they both win their matches and it
looks like over here on the last board
uh
mike
uh
eberly is having a difficult day as tom
the third time of the tournament
tom fats has just
won already took a rook took a piece
traded off opened up the f-file got the
pieces in the game and that's check
and
mate not oh
checkmate checkmate so dardy
already up a point
already up a point in their their match
as well we could be heading to playoffs
okay that's enough looking around though
let's check back in on our top board
here see how justin is doing with those
three pieces versus the queen
and slightly awkward i don't know if i
would have gone for this 94 idea i would
have liked to just consolidate a little
bit play rook d8 keep everything
defended you know what i mean play rook
d8 and then take back with the rook and
get this other rook here and just stay
safe just stay safe now the king's in
the center
uh that being said still looks very very
good for black last order of business
here get these rooks doubled on the d
file bam 93 bam we're invading and that
is going to be
uh death that's that's going to be death
you're there's not surviving
not no way to survive that kind of idea
again black's pieces his two knights
have found squares his bishop works well
with his knights and yeah he actually is
using them now to try and pick up this
pawn over here on f4
rook takes c4 uh looks superficially
nice but i think b5 is going to be a
working tactic here for black takes b5
no check here there is a check on a3
there is a check on a3 so maybe you can
get away with taking this pawn maybe you
can do it i i might have uh might have
written a moth here but yeah rook takes
c4 was played
so queen to a3 is what white is relying
on to save the day
but maybe it's good enough yeah b5
played but now hold on hold on here
queen a3 and what are you doing with
your king i guess you can go b4 but then
the queen's just gonna step back
then maybe it's time to uh to bring in
our rooks yeah i i would have liked to
see black bring in the rooks like yester
says i've been quoting astr a lot lately
because i've been watching our uh
romania commentary but yeah he does have
some good phrases of course you have to
invite everyone to the party these guys
they're all in the party everybody's at
the party these guys they're not
partying they're lonely back there on
their starting squares bring them to the
party
wait and i see people talking did white
resign
oh no
oh no alex
didn't see
queen a3 he played rook c7 and then
resigned after knight takes c7 oh my god
oh
no
queen a3
alex you had queen a3 oh boy all right
well
i assume they resigned either they
resigned or they were just having a
quick mid-game chat and then they're
getting back to playing
no he's totally still talking
i'm confused
is his mouth not moving
no they're still playing they're still
playing never mind never mind rook c7
knight c7 queen e4 so maybe maybe alex
blundered his rook and then they had a
quick chat about it they all they all
laughed you know of course this is sort
of a friendly event and then um then
alex realized that you know his team
needs him to win he can't resign he's
still got a queen his opponent doesn't
might as well keep playing so
no resignation there but now with with
justin picking up an extra rook should
be very very good for edward jones
meanwhile we have a result on board two
uh alex has expected has defeated tom
stack so again looking very good for
edward jones which means again this
doherty matchup is going to be all the
more important so i'm actually going to
jump to board one over there and let's
see how eli asrati is doing against
steve gilmore
um and the answer is
it's it's a struggle they're battling
they're battling here uh looks like a
queen and bishop end game
black is up a couple pawns and
it should be enough to win to be honest
with you it should be enough to win you
know opposite colored bishops these end
games tend to be drawn
but three pawns is too many
three pawns is too many
and instead we saw b take c3 first this
is the same end game though not a lot
different here
and we actually are following the
players we got king c2 bishop f6
and it looks like somehow this has all
happened
and while they're moving at lightning
pace okay we're up to king e3 and let me
do a quick little jump back and forth so
we can follow along live
c5 and it looks like black knows what
he's doing here
um
yeah so white attempting to blockade on
these light squares but the pawns i
think are just going to be too far away
for that to work uh but black does need
to show some creativity here to get it
done uh by the way we have another
result board three uh maurice perry has
one for ascension so this match is tied
one and one again doherty would need to
win this match in order to make the
playoffs
we saw king f5 so
eli absolutely needs to hold here and on
board two chris cell has defeated tom
schaffer by checkmate rook d8 is mate
after knight f3 looks this looks like a
absolutely insane game
um but that means if eli is ready can
hold this game he brings his team into
the playoffs
he brings his team to the playoffs with
uh with a draw here
um a draw or a loss not gonna be enough
that would allow his team to draw the
match but drawing the match does not get
them to the playoffs
ooh and i don't like this last move by
eli king g4 not the way not gonna be the
way
if there's one story here tonight it's
it's the end game
these games
have been decided uh
sort of
an absurd amount in the end game okay
bishop e4 was played
and that's gonna allow b5 is b5 going to
get played
oh and they're chatting never a good
sign
uh oh yep looks like the pawns are
rolling the pawns are rolling
yeah that's it that's going to be it
king d2
b3
nothing doing for white again three
pawns is just too many pawns
still hopes for still mate still some
still made ideas
um let's see here how do i still mate
myself
it's actually not so easy
not so easy to still make myself takes
here and even queens is there's there's
a square yep
yep no good the dream
is over
the dream is dead it was quite an effort
by dougherty again they were by far the
underdogs in this uh in this match in
all of their matches but they nearly
made the playoffs they nearly uh
nearly tied edward jones for the lead or
i guess still enterprise could come back
and and win their match
but uh
this would have been quite the story to
see doherty in uh playoffs for for
everything again
if they had won this game it would have
all come down to one single armageddon
game when anything can happen and
looking at the board here checkmate has
not been played yet
so anything could happen but
there it is and the game's over so
ascension just barely manages to tie
darty in this match and end their hopes
of winning the spring season meanwhile
we have another result steve evans was
the next to end his game
with
what i can only assume is a win on the
clock i wouldn't imagine
uh ken resigned here i mean it is
winning for white but i wouldn't imagine
uh ken ken just resigning maybe he saw
queen e8 though and said enough is
enough i i'm not gonna win this game
um and with that justin beckstead has
also just won what happened to the queen
where did the queen go
where did the queen go ah check
in knight g3 look at this nastiness
okay knight g3 hits the queen and if you
take
um i mean of course you can take but i
assume like
uh something like this was gonna happen
but i think the best you can do is
actually just capture this piece but
instead the queen fell
and justin
won the game with a nice little cute
little check made here that one's nice i
like that one look at that look at those
horses look at those horses go fun stuff
um and with that i i think it's official
i think enterprise ends on one and a
half points doherty ends on one and a
half points and edward jones has won
their match and with that last handshake
uh
that's that's it edward jones is your
corporate chess league spring season
champions they've done it all they
for pete i well not quite a four-peat
because enterprise one in the middle but
i think they are now our four-time
corporate chesley champions alex is
going to be happy the league
commissioner once again getting his team
together rallying the troops and
bringing it home when it when it counts
the most they weren't the number one
seed going into today that was
enterprise but they got it done and that
final round enterprise was leading
leading the finals and then bam
ran into edward jones with their very
formidable team justin beckstead
definitely winning the mvp award here
tonight if i were giving it out won all
of his games and was just a force on
board one justin beckstead and what a
final game for him as well winning with
those three pieces against the queen fun
stuff and they're in the tournament hall
we're just looking at uh all those
players roaming around enjoying the uh
the victory enjoying them and just
enjoying the night i think
so
tons of fun stuff i think that that is
just about all i have for you guys huge
congratulations to edward jones huge
congratulations to everybody who came
out here tonight super fun to have all
of these players back at the chess club
i know i enjoy uh covering these games
they're always interesting always
exciting if this looks like fun to you
and you are a member of a corporation in
the st louis area please reach out to us
we would love to have you join the
league we would love to have you guys
come out to more events like this i want
to see this league grow i want to see it
flourish i want to see more chess in st
louis and hopefully you guys do as well
uh so with that in mind my name is caleb
denby i want to thank you all very much
for watching the season finale the
finals for the corporate chess league
spring season once again congratulations
to edward jones and all the players here
tonight
and i will see you guys in the fall
you